good evening
if i could ask you all to take your
seats
my name is michael murray and i work in
institutional advancement here at the
college
i also have the privilege and honor of
being a united states marine
it's my pleasure to welcome you here
tonight to our
talk america's nobility leadership and
exceptional
exceptionalism of americans veterans
i have the honor and privilege of
serving as the mc
and host also our distinguished guest
major general brady having spent the
last 24 hours with general brady i can
tell you
that you are all in for a very special
evening
with the chance to hear from this great
american patriot
and hero last night as i drove general
brady from the airport to campus he
mentioned to me that when he was awarded
the medal of honor in 1969
there were just over 400 living medal of
honor recipients
currently general brady is one of 69
living medal of honor recipients so this
truly could be a once in a lifetime
opportunity
for all of us here tonight and for that
i think you will all join me in being
extremely grateful
here at hillsdale we start all events
with an invocation
and the pledge and leading us tonight
will be a very special person
in my research on general brady i got to
see some of his
talks over the years and he takes great
pride
in talking about the military spouse and
i think he'll probably cover that topic
tonight
well this evening we have our own
military spouse with us
mrs roma rogers roma is married to
hillsdale's
own associate dean of men jeff rogers
affectionately known around campuses
chief
roma spent 26 years serving our nation
as a navy spouse
during which time she moved the rogers
family all over the globe
stationed on both the east and west
coasts of the continental united states
to oconus outside the continental
united states duty stations in iceland
and japan
roman jeff ended their career in the
navy in lansing michigan
upon jeff's retirement he came to work
at hillsdale
roma herself works in higher education
at spring arbor
please join me in welcoming an
outstanding military spouse
mrs roma rogers
good evening everyone would you please
bow your head for prayer
dear heavenly father lord i praise you
lord i thank you lord for being the one
only lord
i thank you for our men and women
who have served as well lord
the ones who have the ones who are and
the ones who will
do to come lord i ask for strength
stability and support
as you continue and as they continue
to be within your will lord
i praise you and i thank you in jesus
bless his name i pray amen
please stand for the pledge
i cannot see
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation
under god individual liberty
and this is for all thank you
before we get to the main event this
evening we have the honor of witnessing
the inaugural
awarding of the admiral peter hess
beckwith memorial scholarship
this scholarship is given in honor of
admiral beckwith's service to our nation
and as a board member of the hillsdale
county veterans hall of valor
before i ask the presenter to join us
let me take a moment to share with you
a little bit about admiral beckwith
admiral breckwith was born in battle
creek michigan and graduated from
hillsdale college in 1961.
following that admiral beckwith earned
his masters of theology and
served in ministry his entire life in
his civilian life he
served as the episcopal bishop of
springfield illinois before retiring in
2010
and returning to hillsdale college where
he served as our college chaplain until
2016.
admiral beckwith served our nation in
the chaplain core of the united states
navy reserve for 27 years
rising through the ranks to serve as the
deputy chief of chaplains
for the naval reserves retiring as a
rear admiral
i first met admiral beckwith when i
started working for the college in 2011
and because he had spent so many years
in the navy serving the marine corps
he would always remind me that the
marine corps
part of the department of navy i would
affectionately refer to him that's right
the men's department
because of that he took a liking to me
and we became close friends
and he became an invaluable mentor to me
in september 2019 admiral beckwith was
diagnosed with cancer and a month later
the good lord
called him home i think i speak for all
the college and the hillsdale community
when i say that the loss of admiral
beckwith
hit us hard and we dearly miss his
infectious enthusiasm in
all things related to the hillsdale
community
and our great nation admiral beckwith is
survived by his wife melinda
also a hillsdale college graduate and
outstanding military spouse
and his sons peter and michael and their
families and i'm pretty sure the
beckwith family are watching tonight via
our live stream and i offer our best
wishes to them
as we honor admiral beckwith joining us
this evening to present the scholarship
to the very first recipient is dr john
williams also a hillsdale college
graduate
dr williams serves as president of the
board for the hillsdale county
hall of valor dr williams served on that
board with admiral beckwith and he joins
us tonight
please join me in welcoming dr williams
to the stage
thank you
i'm also an air force veteran and
spent 22 years in the air force so we're
well represented tonight with our
our veterans but it's my pleasure
tonight to
award the first memorial scholarship to
the
as the admiral peter hess beckwith
memorial scholarship
to a young lady who's one of the
hillsdale county high schools
seniors this year we offered this
scholarship to
applicants from any of the hillsdale
county high schools
and we had a great many
applicants to compete for this
scholarship and
it's my pleasure to tell you a little
bit about this year's winner
and her name is raeanne van aiken
as i mentioned a senior at camden
frontier high school
and she participates in basketball
and track she's also in 4-h
she showed animals in 4-h and was a
super show woman and she's
also a member of
the future farmers of america and she
is involved in several volunteer
community activities
her letters letters of recommendation
said that
rayanne gives everything she has she
goes all out for every anything she's
involved in
so if she commits to something she's
going to do her best she sets the
examples for
her peers and for others in the
community
so she has done a lot into the community
and
her letters of recommendations were
outstanding
in her essay she highlighted that
she was thankful that some of her family
members had served as veterans
and she talked a little bit about her
great grandfather who was
a world war ii vet and her grandfather
who is a vietnam
vet who died of cancer from
agent orange and then she went into
talking about
when she's on the basketball court at
the beginning of
a game she looks across the court
to the veterans who are saluting
the flag during the playing of the
national anthem
she thinks about all that she's thankful
for for what they have sacrificed and
done for the rest of us so
she was the one that the board members
picked to be our award winner
this uh evening and i'm honored to
congratulate
raeanne van aiken
and the scholarship is for fifteen
hundred dollars to
the university she chooses to go to
congratulations raeanne
tonight we have dr peter jennings here
to not only introduce our guests of
honor but to help us learn a little bit
more about hillsdale
college's rich military heritage dr
jennings is
the associate professor of management
and the mcintyre
chair in business administration he
joined hillsdale college faculty in 2016
teaching and also teaches undergraduate
graduate and executive education
courses in leadership ethics and
management
dr jennings earned his undergraduate
degree from miami university
his master's in business administration
from michigan state
and his phd in management from arizona
state dr jennings is also a proud
veteran serving as an infantry officer
in the united states marine corps
and research director for the u.s army's
center for army profession and ethics
at the united states military academy at
west point
his military service includes three
combat tours in the gulf
iraq and afghanistan in which he earned
numerous personal awards including a
bronze
star medal with v device for valor
since coming to hillsdale dr jennings
has been a champion
advocate for our student veterans
helping them get the support they needed
to be successful students dr jennings is
extremely passionate in helping our
hillsdale community
understand the importance of the
connection the college has
to military service and it is my honor
to welcome dr peter jennings who will
also introduce our guest speaker dr
peter jennings
it was may 10th 1864.
a cool foggy virginia morning
sergeant moses loose has just lost five
of his seven
soldiers in a failed attack on a rebel
position heavily defended
as his decimated regiment regrouped at
the original battle line sergeant loose
heard someone calling him from the field
loose i'm bleeding to death i'm bleeding
to death
he knew the voice it was one of his old
college friends
and he apparently was dying under the
guns of the enemy
where he would die if left without help
sergeant lutz dropped his musket left
open
left over the ditch and rushed out onto
the field
forward towards the rebel lines he felt
the musket balls whizzing past his head
he found the soldier lying prostrate one
leg shattered by grape shot
he stooped down over him and said
lefleur
i have come for you he got the floor on
his back
and as low as he could almost creeping
he carried him back to
through his own lines to a little house
he found the regimental surgeon
the four's leg was shattered below the
knee the surgeon had to amputate it
and bound up his wounds but lefleur's
life was saved
thus did sergeant loose rescue his
wounded
college friend and comrade
and for this action sergeant loose was
awarded the congressional medal of honor
he was the second of three hillsdale
college students
who would receive that honor during the
civil war
a hundred years later a major patrick
brady
would accomplish similar rescues
not in the mountains of virginia but in
the mountains and jungles of vietnam
you would not rescue one soldier but
more than 5 000
american and vietnamese soldiers as well
as civilians and even some enemy
and he did not do it using black
cadillacs
for his ambulance
but in the air using uh-1 huey
helicopters for his ambulance
but unlike the rebels who ceased firing
when they saw sergeant what sergeant
luce was doing
general brady's enemies wouldn't show
him the same courtesy
but like sergeant loose general brady
would also receive the congressional
medal of honor for his actions
among many other awards for valor and
meritorious service
major general patrick brady was born in
1936 in phillips south dakota
he graduated from seattle university in
1959 was commissioned as second
lieutenant the army medical services
corps
he served 34 years in the army in all
stations around the world he was in
berlin
in 1961 when the wall went up and he was
there again in 1989 when it went down
he served two tours in vietnam as a
helicopter ambulance pilot general brady
is one of our country's most decorated
living
veterans he's the only living army
veteran to hold both
the medal of honor and a distinguished
service cross our nation's highest
second highest award
a list of his other military awards
include two distinguished service medals
the defense superior service medal the
legion of merits six distinguished
flying crosses two bronze stars one for
valor
53 air models one for balor and the
purple heart
and there are others he's recognized as
the top helicopter pilot in vietnam
and is a member of both the army
aviation and the dust off hall of fame
general brady and his wife nancy now
deceased had six children
all of them served in the military megan
served in the army medical services
corps and is a veteran of the iraq war
those are just some of the highlights of
general brady's military cv
if you will for the benefit of our
students i want to add a little color
to this extraordinary service record
general brady was a pioneer and a leader
of the famed army dust-off units
medical service units that specialize in
aeromedical
evacuations the call sign
dustoff came about because their
choppers would literally disappear in a
cloud of dust
that they turned up when they took off
from the pickup zone
but dust off signified more than a radio
call sign
it was via it was the vietnam grunts
911.
as i should say uh 911. sorry for the
slip
up there it was the grunts 9-1-1 the
call they would make when they needed
medical help and the dust-off units
proved
reliable first responders general
brady's dustoff unit
rescued more than 21 000 patients
and remarkably they never left a patient
in the field
in total army dust-off units were
directly responsible for saving
close to 1 million lives and as noted
general brady would be personally
responsible
for saving more than 5 000 lives
such exceptional performance was the
fruit of highly innovative
tactical techniques developed by general
brady
some of them against army regulations
but they enabled
his unit to conduct rescue missions
day or night in any kind of terrain or
weather
24 hours a day seven days a week
such high risk gila born rescue missions
came with a price
dust-off crews and pilots faced more
endangered and suffered
the highest casualty rate of any
aviation units in vietnam
i read general brady's book
that recounts his vietnam experiences
dead men flying
it's a fascinating read
among many things i gained a new
appreciation for those long
under appreciated vietnam veterans
also notable in the book is that general
brady doesn't dwell on himself
he gives credit to his mentors and
senior leaders especially his first
commander major charles kelly
the father of dustoff and of course his
crew members
it seems general brady's martial courage
is topped
only by his christian humility
so i'd also like to just add a few
highlights anticipating that general
brady might not
expand on these too much about his
actions that
earned him the medal of honor the
missions began before sunrise
and they lasted long into the night
non-stop
without a break first mission were two
vietnamese soldiers they were isolated
on a mountaintop
fog a hundred miles deep seven rescue
attempts had already failed general
brady got
him out second mission 60 casualties
heavy fog again surrounded by enemy
two helos had already been shot down and
numerous other attempts
to rescue them had failed general brady
got him out
third mission two wounded
soldiers heavy enemy contact
general brady got him out under fire
there was other missions 12 casualties
rescued
there was one harrowing rescue mission
in a minefield
50 casualties general brady was able to
land in a minefield
and get him out
general variety described that day as a
three aircraft day
he lost two aircraft he didn't stop
he got them all out 111 they estimate
lives were saved by general grady and
his crew that day
it was for these missions for this
service and sacrifice above and beyond
the call of duty that earned him the
medal of honor
that brings me back to sergeant loose
and hillsdale college civil war veterans
moses luce and his friend asher lafleur
are among
400 hillsdale college students that
served in the civil war
some notable notable facts about these
400 all were christian patriots who
fought to preserve the union
and defend liberty and abolish slavery
all were volunteers
and most including lewis and lefleur
volunteered at the very start of the war
and served for the duration
or until they were wounded or killed
half became officers three became
regimental commanders one became a
general many acquitted themselves with
exceptional courage
including three as already noted who won
medal of honor
and at least 16 and possibly many more
maybe up to 200 our records aren't
certain because many of our students
went back to their home states to serve
and we don't have records
died in service during the war and many
more
suffered grievous and debilitating
wounds this service record that i'm
highlighting
is exceptional among american colleges
indeed so great was hillsdale college
civil war service that the detroit
advertiser tribune the leading newspaper
at the time noted
that probably no college in the country
is better represented in union army than
hillsdale it has sent its young men to
war by the hundreds
and they have watered with their blood
every battlefield
in the republic and here's my point
all colleges of higher learning pursue
truth we pursue truth
but we also defend liberty
defending liberty is a tradition of this
college
it defines who we are and what we stand
for as a college community
that tradition was born in the service
and sacrifice of the students of the
civil war
generation and it is memorialized in the
soldiers monument the sands center in
our campus in front of central hall
this tradition has been passed down as
an inheritance a sacred trust from one
hillsdale college generation to the next
and hillsdale college students have
remained faithful to that trust
serving in every branch of our armed
forces in every war
and during peace time
because of this tradition hillsdale
college
honors the long blue line
of men and women who have defended
liberty by
serving in our armed forces from the
civil war
to vietnam from the revolution
to iraq and afghanistan
is therefore fitting especially on this
veterans day
that we have the high honor of welcoming
tonight one of our country's greatest
military heroes
now i'd like to ask you to stand and
join me
in welcoming major general major general
patrick brady
oh lord
thank you thank you very much
i really love to hear what a fine fellow
i am
i just wish my wife could be here to
hear a fun fine fellow i am but more
than that i wish my wife's mother could
be here
it's dangerous to have a general you
know there's three kinds of generals
those that get that can count and those
that can't count
now before i start i got strict
instructions
to recognize from texas
sophie and rose coster who are students
here and have
relatives in texas and read law
so if i didn't do that it'd be trouble
when i get back to my neighborhood
excuse me alexander sultanison warned
about the dangers
of a nation amputating his memory of
silent generations growing old
and dying without ever talking about
themselves
either to each other or to their
descendants
so i'm going to talk to you about some
life lessons from my generation and from
those we honor today
american veterans american veterans
believe that life has
no meaning unless lived for the benefit
of future generations
and some of us do this actually
as a way to live our lives over again
i saw a poll that said many of us would
do things differently if we could do it
over again if we could live our lives
over again
i know i'm not the man i would have
liked to be can't change all that
however the truth is we can do it over
again
just not for ourselves too late
but we can do it over again through our
children through the young people
none of us are failures if our children
succeed if we can help children
all children all young people succeed
so how do we do that someone said that
every
so-called hero at last becomes a boar
now i'm going to talk to you about some
heroes those of us who wear the medal of
honor and other heroes our veterans
do to keep from becoming bores at the
same time we kind of live our lives over
again
a boss once told me after i'd really
messed something up he said don't feel
bad pat
no one is a complete failure they can
always serve as a bad example
and that's why a guy like me even as a
bad example
why we still have some worth
you can't live as long as i have messed
up as often as i have and not
have something worthwhile to pass on
for the benefit of future generations
now we find a recurring plea
among many disadvantaged students to
teachers and others
that you have not been where we've been
and that of course is true in many cases
however
it's not true about our veterans they
have been
where those students have been and then
some
it's hard for a student no matter how
disadvantaged he may be
to make that case to a one-armed or
one-eyed veteran
now we learned that we know that
learning is most effective with
witnesses
we hear that some teachers tell some
explain
some and some demonstrate but i believe
the best teachers inspire
and for this reason the medal of honor
recipients veterans
so-called heroes can be uniquely
effective as teachers and role models
for many students
now we've used this metal as a training
aid
to form our character development
program which we've spread across
america
for the last 15 years or so it's
available it's online is free
and i hope that this this great college
will take a look at it
what do we mean by character it's not
as we are told who you are when you're
alone
being alone does not magically identify
you we all have a high regard for
ourselves
merit it or not by character i mean
the you god knows now we all go about
this
in our own way many of us may moralize a
bit
which i personally think we need more of
some people don't like moralizing
i believe for the most part it's because
they don't like morals
but i will tell you how i do it when i
speak to the students out there and also
to the teachers
i explain that this medal is a symbol
symbol is from the greek word meaning
half token
which when joined with the other half
represents something above and beyond
itself much greater than itself
for example the other half token of our
flag is the constitution and the
declaration
when you burn or disrespect old glory
you
burn and disrespect our founding
documents
the other half token of this medal is
courage
sacrifice and patriotism the foundation
of our sovereignty
our freedom and our future these are the
values
behind the valor valor is finite
values are infinite in fact both
valor and values come from the same same
latin root valerie
but within that symbolism the symbolism
of the metal is the key to success in
life to happiness in life
and to the security of our nation i
believe
and i i thought i was going to be
talking to mostly young people here and
i think we have some of them
but i believe that most young people
most of us are interested in
not only in being successful in life but
also being happy
so i'm going to focus on the keys to
success and happiness
and success and happiness can be a
function of who your heroes are so i'm
going to define for you what a hero
is and freedom i think
it is very important to understand who
is responsible for our freedom
and how to stay free so i'm going to
explain that
and of course at the end there's a test
now i don't know if i can give a test
to some of you guys out here but i'm
going to try
now america has no kings or queens no
dukes or duchesses
but we do have a nobility america
as nobility is what this day is all
about
our veterans their titles are private
and sergeant grunt for
my friend steve lieutenant in general
are simply gi at the top however
is the kia the wia and the pow
unlike other nobilities their titles
were not inherited
they were earned through their blood
sweat and tears
and that is the hallowed trinity that
secures our freedom
the blood sweat and tears of our
nobility
without veterans without our nobility we
would not
be free veterans are the vault for the
values of america
and that is what we would like to see
honored the values for which we fought
i believe that the highest form of
patriotism is service
to our youth and what is most important
is that our youth know and understand
these values
and know that values are what we honor
when we honor our veterans
they brought freedom to so many not just
our allies but our enemies as well
and the young people need to know this
and they need to know about those who
did not make it
those who sacrificed all the spring
times of their life so that liberty
might grow old
they need to know that the noblest part
of their being did make it
it stays with us becomes a part of our
being
as a people everywhere in this great
land
a part of our common ideals and feelings
we have for each other
of all those things that make us a
united country
a singular people of people who enjoy
each other's company and wish
each other well a preacher friend once
said
to me that if love is to survive
it must be expressed now that's so true
in our families in our workplace and our
in our
units if it is to survive it must be
expressed
but it's true of other expressions as
well honoring veterans
and our heroes they do not believe they
did this country a favor by their
service and sacrifice
they believe that god did them a favor
by allowing them to be born here
now let me add to america's nobility
their families
and that exquisite creature known as the
military wife
there she is
i've been almost dead many times
but i never went through anything as
agonizing is when my daughter went into
combat
and i wasn't there to protect her our
wives have gone
gone through this over and over again as
we deploy
and come back and deploy again i believe
that adam's rib
was the greatest investment in history
c.s lewis in his condemnation of moral
relativism
and a valueless society he wrote about
men without chess
and i'm sure you folks here have studied
him what a great writer
he was the chest for lewis symbolizes
spiritual element
the value center of a person it was the
indispensable connection between the
head
the intellectual the mental element and
the belly
the visceral emotional passionate part
of our nature
balance comes when the head rules the
belly
through the chest danger comes from
peoples and nations without
chest from intellectuals without values
human animals governed by passion and
instinct and power alone
true evil is not a disease it's a
decision
and the world is full of evil and those
who don't have chest
veterans are kind of like america's
chest they are as i said the vault for
our values
they have protected us us from those
among us and those in the world
who don't have chess so what do veterans
teach us about the keys to success
in life i'm sure by now that
many of you young people and certainly
the rest of you know that life is not
fair
we are simply not all born equal
certainly not in terms of ability and
opportunity
look around you're going to see many who
are smarter bigger faster
stronger better athletes better looking
and most important they have better hair
than you do
and you will find those who were born
with so much more opportunity
than you did but none of that is
important
because in the most important way we are
all born equal
and that way is in terms of courage each
of us can have all the courage we want
you can't use it up god has made this
marvelous gift
infinitely available to each one of us
and guess what
courage is the key to success in life
it's a great and proven equalizer in
life it produces great people
from those among us who were not born
with great ability
who were not given great opportunity
and once we realize that we can have all
the courage we want
and that is the key to success in life
it eliminates
all those distractions as to who and
what
we can be mediocrity and failure become
choices they have nothing to do with
chance
you can be as successful as you have the
courage to be
and god will give you all the courage
you want
if we agree on this we see
that in many ways failure is a function
of cowardice
by by the way this business of
self-esteem what does that even mean
participation trophies i think that
unmerited self-esteem is a success
killer
many of us are way up here in our
opinions of ourselves
way down here in our performance which
should be
how we judge ourselves veterans are
mostly known for battlefield
physical kind of courage but moral and
courage
moral courage is the most important
moral courage is the courage to overcome
the fears that are present in daily life
the stresses of study of grades of
personal relationships and
responsibilities
and the worst fear i think of all is
that we might let
someone down our family our co-workers
our fellow soldiers
those fears are as intense as any in
combat
physical courage can win a battle or a
ball game
but moral courage can change
the world and by the way
courage is not a guy thing in my life it
is the women who were the most
courageous
where were the apostles during their
crucifixion
they ran only his mother and the women
stayed with him no battle for
field courage greater than the courage
of motherhood
they understand the two o'clock in the
morning courage that
napoleon talked about no pain a soldier
can suffer
to match that of child birth
and look at the olympics look at that
horizontal wooden beam
have you ever seen a man on that thing
are you kidding me
now as an aside wealth can be a part of
success
and our need our youth need to reject
the demonization of the successful by
some who themselves are demeaned by
their envy
my experience with the wealthy in
america is that they are smarter than i
am
they work harder than i do they are more
competitive and more courageous than i
am
and only sometimes are they luckier than
i am
most of the wealthy i know are very
generous and for good reason
many of them know what it means to be
poor
they had the courage to work their way
out which is what
makes america what it is i heard a
lecture recently
on the value of failure in the lives of
the successful
i think it's important for young people
to know that many of the most successful
people have failed more
than those who are considered failures
the successful kept competing they were
courageous the failures quit
no such thing as failure unless we fail
to learn from it risk
if risk is a father of innovation
failure is a mother of success
jimmy doolittle a great american medal
of honor
recipient and a man who i had the
privilege to know
he put it pretty well when he said i
believe in excellence
and i believe in reward for excellence
i've tried all my life to do things as
well as i could do them
sometimes successfully sometimes i
failed
there have been disappointments and
successes and the successes are what you
enjoy
most but the disappointments
may be what you learn from the most
because you can analyze what happened
and you're better prepared
to cope the next time jimmy doolittle
opened the skies for commercial aviation
in america
we ought not to fail and be considered a
winner but we
can fail and learn how to be a winner
the big danger is in losers who think
they are winners
and who failed to change a great golfer
friend of mine told me that his children
who did not make it in the pros were
better golfers than he was
but they failed to learn from their
mistakes
courage i would define and
everybody i guess has their own
definition but for me courage
i would define as reaching a breaking
point
but not breaking but courage is part
but only part of heroism later we will
define the source of courage but let's
first define the indispensable component
of a hero
heroes may be courageous in all elements
of our humanity
physical great athlete mental and
einstein moral
great religious leader but there must be
one
key ingredient in anyone we look up to
as a hero and let me give you an example
of a true hero his name was
james coleman they called him papi now
pappy was probably
20 years old but he was the oldest of my
medics and so all the other guys were
teenagers so he was pappy
one mission when he got out of the
chopper
to retrieve the wounded from the
battlefield he was shot in the chicken
plate
which is armor knocked him down
got up went back for the boom he got
shot again knocked down they finally
found the sniper killed the sniper he
got up and went and got the patients out
of the battlefield
the next mission he took around
right through his lips when the crew
rushed to help him he said
not to worry i just kissed the bullet
that had my name on it
later he was with me in a minefield
everyone there was dead
wounded and would not move
pappy ran into the minefield began
rescuing the wounded
now things were going good one
unfortunately one trip he set off a mine
it blew him and the crew chief up in the
air and filled the aircraft with
shrapnel
set his pants on fire he landed put the
fire out
went back and got the patience and
loaded him on my helicopter i took him
in the wounded of the hospital thank god
he lived
in one year he probably helped rescue
over three thousand wounded
earning dozens of medals to include
three purple hearts
three silver stars he's in the army
aviation hall of fame
there's no way to measure this man's
courage
but that is not why he is a hero with 18
years of service
two years short of his pension his
family called
they needed him he could have been
sergeant major of the army
but he left his career he left his
pension and went home to take care of
his family
coleman was not a hero just because he
was courageous
he was a hero because he was also a good
person the key ingredient
is goodness there should be no such
thing as a bad
person who we call a hero
our society confuses heroes and
celebrities and this is dangerous to
young people
they will emulate their heroes often
celebrities
are not always good people
celebrity is someone who we may want to
meet
a hero is someone who we should want to
be like
someone like pappy coleman we need
more heroes who wear dog tags not capes
ride a fire truck rather than a horse
and drive a patrol car rather than a
formula one
by the way one of the great honors of my
life was when pappy's wife called me
he'd been sick took us 30-some years to
find him
and he was he was not well he was never
well
and it was a great happy night for me my
beloved san antonio spurs had just
kicked miami's butt in the finals
and i was happy and she told me papi was
dying
and i said rose i know he's dying but
he's not going to die today
and she says yes he is and she wanted
she told me that his last wish was that
i'd be in charge of his journal and he
died a couple hours after that
he wanted to be buried in turkey creek
kentucky
that's hatfield mccoy country they don't
speak english in
turkey creek kentucky i had
some very clear guidance from papi on
how he wanted me to bury
him i was really having trouble
communicating with him but we got it
done
and he got all his wishes as far as his
burial went
now what's the key to courage
what activated activates it in each one
of us
fear of course is an emotion
courage is a decision
and so many so-called heroes are only
doing that which they had to do
out of fear medal of honor recipients
would know this
and we know that that's why so many of
us do not deserve this medal
but there's a story about a football
player that illustrates for me
the key to courage he was not a very
good player
but his team was going to a bowl game
many years ago in those days they
traveled by train
he got word along the way that his dad
was very ill so he turned around went
back his dad died
and shortly after the funeral he caught
the train
came back and joined his team at the
bowl game
on the day of the game he pleaded with
the coach to let him play
as i said he was not very good but the
coach decided that in memory of his
father they would let him start and then
get him out
before he did any damage well he played
sensationally
they kept him in he was all over the
place in fact scored the winning
touchdown
the coaches were amazed of course and
delighted
and asked him how did you do it
he said my dad was blind all my life
and this was the first time he could
watch me play
it took courage for that young man to be
willing to ask his coach to play in such
an important game and to compete
against the very best under great
pressure
but it was his faith that gave him the
courage this football player had faith
that his blind father was there
could finally see and was watching him
play football for the first time
and that faith inspired his courageous
play
the foundation of courage is faith the
two are often confused but it's only
rationale
i've been able to articulate to explain
some of the things i've seen in life and
in combat
in combat i coped with my fear through
my faith
my faith was for me a substitute for
fear it was source of calm of comfort
and it gave me confidence to do things
that for me would have otherwise been
impossible
i never really experienced fear in
combat saving lives
fear is a debilitating thing it's a
horrible thing to see
it'll cause to happen that which caused
it
so i knew if i got killed doing what i
was doing what a great way to die
trying to save the lives of my fellow
soldiers
fear is really our faith on trial our
faith
under fire faith destroys fear
when fear knocks at your door door send
faith to answer
and fear will be gone when you open the
door
i can define my faith i could not do it
for others
i would not try but somehow
it's all tied to love and to sacrifice
and in a simple belief that there's
something beyond a particular time
someone above and beyond the self
something beyond this life
that makes living and dying worthwhile
i've never known anyone with enduring
repetitive
courage who was not also a person
of faith now what do veterans teach us
about the key to happiness in life
now an old dustoff pilot friend of mine
said happiness
was to have someone to love something to
do
and something to look forward to a lot
of truth in that
but i mentioned sacrifice which is
like courage not well understood but it
is the key
i believe to happiness one can be very
successful
and not be happy so let me define it for
you first
here's what my friend hannah how she
defined it and letter she wrote to me
she's about nine or so
she said sacrifice sacrifice means
giving to some
giving to someone something you could
have had
for yourself i believe it is best if
everyone
sacrifices for example
i gave my little sister my last cupcake
now i think canna has a lot of it but i
would define
sacrifice as love in action
you take that great emotion love and you
do something with it
something non-verbal like a cupcake
it's a sacrifice of great leaders of
teachers of parents
of coaches coaches especially of our
veterans
it's special a sacrifice no bottom line
no material gain no quid pro quo
all it will do is increase your capacity
for more sacrifice and i believe it will
also increase one's capacity for
fulfillment
for responsibility and i believe for
happiness itself
the more you sacrifice the more you are
able to sacrifice
the better you get at it and the happier
you become
also the greater your capacity for
sacrifice the greater will be your
capacity for responsibility and
leadership
it's like lifting weights the more you
lift the stronger you get
sacrifice is kind of like love lifting
exercising love on behalf of our fellow
human beings
and i would also add gratitude
as a source of happiness sadly lacking
in some of us but
i think it's essential to happiness how
can one be happy and not know how much
we have to be grateful for
as i said most veterans don't believe we
did america
serve favor by our sacrifice we believe
god did us a favor
by allowing us to be born in this great
country we are grateful
we are happy to be americans a friend of
mine
who was a pow for six years
said that happiness for him
was having a doorknob on the inside of
his room
he was grateful just to be free just to
get up in the morning and see that
doorknob
military people others too are
accustomed to discipline
now may it may sound odd but i think
discipline is also a source of happiness
we read that the lord disciplines those
he loves
and that there is no justice without
love
very often to be the object of
discipline means we are the object of
somebody's love
and that should make us happy i used to
tell my soldiers that you can't
care for soldiers and not correct them
now it's been said that love and
practice is a harsh and dangerous thing
compared to love and dreams i've kept
over my desk for many years
james russell lowell saying all the
beautiful sentiments in the world
weigh less than a single lovely action
an act of love a sacrifice i think
marriage reminds us of this truth
it's easy to profess our love much more
difficult are the sacrifices that prove
it
and i think our wives make this point
very clear
they want some proof nonverbal usually
expensive
proof that we love them
but it's through sacrifice that we show
our love for our country
our patriotism and if you agree with my
definition of sacrifice it's easy to see
that a soldier's love
our military's love is the foundation
for the security of our people
and for that reason it's vital
that we be a lovable people worthy of
our soldiers sacrifice
now what do veterans teach us about the
key to our future
which brings me to patriotism which is
the key
to our future a patriot is not someone
who
says simply they love their country
the patriot is someone who's willing to
prove they love their country through
their support and defense of their
country
a patriot is by definition someone who
is extremely
proud of their country now unfortunately
for the first time in many years
gallup asked young people how proud they
were
to be americans fewer than a majority
for the first time said they are
extremely proud
the source of this change may be that
patriotism not
is not as emphasized in education as it
once was
a democratic society cannot survive
without patriots now another source of
our declining pride in america may be
the dismal state of our basic knowledge
of who we are as a nation
and i understand here in this great
college
you focus a lot on that a recent survey
found that only one in six americans can
pass a quiz on basic american history
it's frightening but true that one in
seven high school students
believe that we started world war ii by
dropping the atomic bomb on japan
we cannot love who we are if we don't
know who we are
that the kind and based on a lack of
pride and knowledge of america could
prove disastrous
in any demanding crisis of the future
if you doubt that just look at the
ignorance of some of our politicians
about who we are
our youth need to be educated and
inspired in the wonders
of our country if we are to survive
young people must love their country if
they are to support
and defend it they must believe we are
lovable people an
exceptional people if this is to work
tough job
when so many do not believe that we are
in any way special
now i have a speech i give on american
exceptionalism
relax i'm not going to give it but it
boils down to three things
we are exceptional because we are an
exceptionally courageous people
we are an exceptionally compassionate
people
and we are an exceptionally competitive
people
and as a famous historian once said
america is great
because america is good we were founded
on good
short for god on a belief in god you
can't have one
without the other now if anyone's got a
better
definition of exceptionalism i'd like to
hear it but i break it down
for example we're free as is most of the
world because of america's courage
mostly our veterans
no country is more generous in their
compassion and care for others
hurricanes tsunamis you name it we are
very very compassionate
in our care for others in the world and
in america
and it's the unleashing of the free
exercise of
competition granted by our
constitution that's the basis of our
prosperity
my bottom line is we will cease to be
exceptional when we cease to be
courageous
compassionate and competitive
and good one example i believe we are
trending to socialism
because we have people who don't want to
compete
perhaps because of cowardice or laziness
or both
now children as i said learn best
through witness through examples
and i think a great example
of patriotism is illustrated by a dear
friend of mine sergeant webster anderson
big powerful black
artillery sergeant early one morning his
attack his unit was attacked by the
communist forces
and the initial attack they pretty much
took off both of his legs
yet he continued to fight later they
threw a hand grenade into his position
and as he caught it and tried to throw
it clear of his men it pretty much
blew off his arm still he fought on
i flew in and picked up what was left of
webster and his wounded
after he had inspired his men to defeat
the communists miraculously
the medic saved his life but his efforts
to save his men
cost him both legs and an arm
but it earned him the medal of honor now
webster and i became very close
he thought i saved his life physician
saved his life
and some years later we were speaking at
a school in oklahoma
and one of the young men raised his hand
and asked webster
if he would do what he did again
knowing what it cost him two legs and an
arm
and webster answer moves me to this day
he raised his good arm and he says kid
i only have one arm left my country can
have it any time
they want i'm sure that those young
people will be forever
inspired by the words of that great
black soldier propped up before them who
is more plastic than he was
flesh his sacrifice was an investment in
their future and i think some of them
realized that for the first time
webster defined patriotism for those
young people
which brings me to the very purpose of
an education
and i think that this is well known here
this is an extraordinary college
i think it's a paradigm for what the
colleges and universities
across this country should be but the
ancients extolled the virtue of piety
which they defined as an intimacy with
god in their case gods
they said it underlies the virtue of
justice
without which we perish piety is often a
joke today much like
chastity the ancient philosophers
believed the purpose of education was
both moral and civil
during the enlightenment time they
changed to the belief that moral and
civic education was not the business of
the state
thomas jefferson was a devoted son of
the enlightenment time but he disagreed
he agreed with the ancients that both
civil and moral were most important
he was so dedicated to education that he
ignored his presidency
on his tombstone and put on it instead
that he was the father of the university
of virginia
jefferson also agreed with another
ancient pericles
on the need for individuals to control
their desires
and even curtail their own rights when
necessary to make sacrifices
in the service of their community
without whose protection civil rights
could not exist
it's another form of patriotism in short
democracy and patriotism were
inseparable
and i would add piety where there is no
democracy without justice
and education must produce patriots the
highest form of patriotism as i say is
service to our youth
we've often in our time seen patriotism
blasted we hear samuel johnson's remark
that patriotism is the last refuge of a
scoundrel
johnson did not mean a real and generous
love of country
but the pretended patriotism which so
many politicians of all ages and
countries
have made as a cloak for their
self-interest
one final point on patriotism i'm
working on this
but it has to do with developing a team
mentality
teaching children to be team players
it's
us in the u.s to be part of something
beyond themselves the unselfish
sacrifice
thing if you are a christian certainly
as a catholic we believe
god is a team three persons
one divine nature i think he designed
mankind
also to be a team the whole person is
really a team
three parts as i mentioned mental moral
and physical
all three need attention need
development or the whole person becomes
unwholesome as a poet john dawn put it
no man is an island entire of itself
every man is a piece of the continent a
part of the main
any man's death diminishes me because i
am involved in mankind
therefore never send to know for whom
the bell is told
it tolls for thee so we're all part of
teams family school city nation etc
something happens to one of us it
happens to all of us
so true of our nation and the need to
grow patriots
now out in the west
where i grew up we used horses to pull
logs out of the woods
and we used to have horse pulling
contests in one contest the winner
pulled
nine thousand pounds and the runner up
pulled something less
than nine thousand pounds they decided
to see
what they could pull together as a team
guess what
as a team they pulled 27 000 pounds
a team mentality is essential in
citizenship and patriotism
and in our future a friend of mine was
rude enough
on the golf course to pull out a tape
measure
which we used to measure closest to the
pin
then he noted our life span 75 inches or
whatever the hell it was
and he says here you are brady the end
of the tape
well for the young people i would say
that here you are
this is your life you're here
someday you'll be here where i am why
not build something in between
a monument in the end i found that the
treasures of life are nothing but
memories
why not good memories start building
those memories
and i think they will be golden if you
follow the golden rule
the ten commandment and the sermon on
the mount which i believe together
condense the wisdom of all time the
great wisdom of all time
be good the golden rule live good the
sermon on the mount
avoid evil the ten commandments
now in my faith we have a doctrine on
grace
it teaches that there's a treasure chest
filled with grace
it was filled by the sacrifice of jesus
and the saints
and it's there to help us all as we
struggle to do what's right
we all draw from that chest of grace
through no particular merits of our own
but simply because of god's love for us
our freedom is like grace a treasure
chest
it was filled by the sacrifices of our
veterans
our heroes our patriots and we all draw
from that
chest of freedom often through no
merits of our own but simply because of
their love
for us the chest of grace
is inexhaustible because it comes from
god
not so the chest of freedom
it must continuously be replenished
by our sacrifices
and so that's my message to you from our
veterans
those who sacrifice their youth that
liberty
might roll old over many years countless
battlefields
over the bodies of millions of dead a
message from this medal
that the values of courage based in
faith
sacrifice based in love will lead to an
incredible capacity
for service to others to patriotism
and eventually to the security of
america peace
as i said is the ultimate victory
of all warriors we must remoralize
america if we are to survive and it
begins with
the likes of you young people here
now can i give you a test or is it are
you all too
beyond that
all right does america have a nobility
if so who
good lord i thought there were smart
people in this college
what's the key to success in life
what's the source of courage what's the
key to happiness in life
how do you find sacrifice
loving action what is essential to a
hero goodness
what's the key to our future patriotism
what is essential to patriotism support
and defend america
and that's the quiz we give to all the
young people that we talk through
talk to throughout america so let me say
thank you for
allowing to be with you god bless you
all you're lucky to be in this great
college
that's for sure
thank you general brady we'll have uh
general brady's going to take a couple
questions so we've got uh
two people in the aisles with uh mike so
if you have a question for general brady
if you could come to the
to the aisles and uh see the two
gentlemen they'll uh
hold the mic for you so when we start on
we have anybody on this side over here
there's a hand there's a hand and
there's the mic sir all right
i just wanted to see what the
significant of the picture is
significant what the picture oh
i didn't see it it's uh that that is a
uh that's a picture
they asked me for some photographs of
vietnam and that was
only one i could find where i'm actually
making a pickup on the battlefield
in vietnam that's a huey helicopter
helicopter ambulance
and they're loading some vietnamese
patients onto the helicopter that was my
first tour
i think we got a question over on that
side thank you for joining us tonight
general brady
you mentioned how the human person is
divided between a physical
mental and moral and i think a lot of
people think of the military
in a more physical sense with going
through boot camp and being in war
and i'm curious how the military has
prepared you and built you up mentally
and morally as well
that's a good question there's no you
know
combat is a very very physical thing
but as i said faith
is the key to courage and the and the
military
the american military is one of the very
few militaries in the world that has a
chaplain's core
and we have we we a soldier will fight
best if he knows he's going to be taken
care of physically
if he gets shot and and
spiritually so we have the chaplains
with him on the battlefield we have the
medics with him on the battlefield
and the military i mean
it is it is of all the things in america
most concerned with the whole man
they keep you physically fit morally
straight
and of course you have the intellectual
challenges of whatever your profession
might be
so i think the military addresses all
three pretty well
did i miss one you look like i didn't
answer your question
i think you did thank you i think that's
it for questions sir another round of
applause for general blake oh all right
the last part of our program is a salute
to each branch of the service
and to lead us is my colleague and
fellow brother navy
marine corps blue green team member jeff
rogers
jeff serves as the college as the
associate dean of men where he helps
shape
and mold the young boys who start out
here as freshmen
into strong men by the time they
graduate jeff is
one of the few people on campus that is
known by one name
chief because of that 26-year navy
service
ending as a chief hospital corpsman as i
mentioned during
my introduction of jeff's wife chief and
his family have served
our nation all over the globe he
finished his career
recruiting for the navy medical service
corps which introduced him to hillsdale
college
after retirement in 2011 he joined the
staff
jeff and i actually started working on
for the college on the very same day in
august of 2011 and it's my pleasure to
introduce
what i refer to as the best man on
campus jeff rogers
okay all right all right
it is very patriotic for us to do this
and so the united states
coast guard you're in the coast guard
stand with me
as we sing the united states coast guard
so here's a coast guard marching song
we sing on land and sea
through surf and storm and howling guilt
i shall our purpose be
semper protest is our guide
our fame our glory to
to fight to save or fight
to die i coast guard we are
for you all right
next the united states air force
off we go into the wild blue yonder
climbing high into the sun
here they come zooming to meet our
thunder
adam boy give him the gun give him the
gun
down we die spotting a flame from under
off with one hell of a roar
we live in fame or go
down in flame hey nothing can stop the
usair force
all right i might add the only anthem
that
has a curse word in it all right the
united states
[Music]
navy
[Applause]
[Music]
anchors away
fair well too foreign
until we meet once more
here's wishing you a hat before at home
maybe the only
one that talks about drinking
the united states army
first to fight for the right and to
build the nation's might
and the army goes rolling along
proud of all we have done fighting to
the battles one and the army goes
rolling along
then it's high high hey the army's on
its way
count off the cadence loud and strong
forever we go
you will always know and the army
goes rolling along
all right
united states marine corps
from the halls of marta
zuma to the shores
of
[Music]
we will fight our country's battles
in the air our land and sea
first to fight for the letter
[Music]
and to keep our honor clean
we are proud to claim the
title of united states
marines
that brings us to the end of the evening
i need to uh a couple things
some housekeeping matters first due to
the
state health department limitation on
indoor gatherings of
no more than 50 guests per reception we
are splitting up the guests
alphabetically for the dessert reception
so
if your last name begins with an a
through m
we will ask you to go to the serial
dining room and n through z
to dow a and b there will be six seats
per table
friends are invited to sit together and
we request that guests remain seating
during the reception
and unfortunately students you're going
to need to go back and study you're
asked not to attend the desert reception
due to the increase in the
in some cases we're seeing secondly and
more importantly
some thank yous i would ask that you
join me in a round of applause to
for some very important people who
helped make tonight possible
the special events team the audio visual
team the dao center staff who provided
outstanding support
that allowed us here on campus to here
and those online to hear and see
general brady's inspirational message
and to our president's office who hosted
this event
and the person on that team gracie
humphries who quarterbacked everything
remotely from north carolina
so thank you gracie and thank you all of
our colleagues and give them a round of
applause
and the last thank you as i give this
thank you i would ask general brady
and his fellow vietnam veterans to
please stand
i think all of the veterans who have
served since vietnam especially in iraq
and afghanistan like myself
we have been the recipients of an
outpouring of support and thanks that
really goes
unmatched you cannot tell somebody that
you
served and not be thanked and
i think that we received some of that
thanks
from some people who did not do that for
the vietnam veterans
i think it's a it's a dark stain on our
nation's history
that we did not give them the
recognition
and the thanks that they deserve so
that's why i ask you to stand
and that's why i like to end tonight
with that thank you again
to those vietnam veterans who served us
so proudly and so well
so thank you vietnam veterans and with
that
thank you for all coming god bless
hillsdale college and god bless the
united states of america
you